good morning millennials
welcome back to the mornington welcome
back to
me and to the studio and to the youtube
channel what up everyone
we are back baby we're back it's been
so long so much has happened there was a
quarantine there was a trip
there was so much there was and
i think it's so important to take time
for yourself because like
i have this zest for life right now like
this is gonna be the best episode
ever wow i'm so excited it's just like i
think
i don't even know how to explain how it
is that i'm feeling and i hope that
everyone who's listening can take time
for themselves
like just a few days away from your job
if you can like it is so refreshing
and to see other people
there's nothing like it there is nothing
like other human beings
and i never thought that's something i
would say i never i hate other people i
never thought that's something that you
would
say either oh it was delicious i just
loved waiting in lines at the airport
like
i was just like living for it nice well
tell us about your trip
oh well it was very long and i apologize
in advance for taking that extra week
off
i think i think we all needed it i'm i'm
not mad about it
i'm happy you got what you needed out of
it i liked you know being
at home and but i'm also so happy to be
back in studio finally but i needed to
miss the studio
that's it it's like you need to miss
don't it always seem to go
that you don't know what you got till
it's gone
literally literally absence makes the
heart grow fonder so i definitely felt
that and i just
i was supposed to leave on monday and
this feeling like of having to leave
was making me so upset i was like i
can't like i was literally gonna cry i'm
like
i love vacation me and i'm tan and i'm
beautiful and i'm excited i don't have
anxiety
so i was with brian because we were
celebrating his birthday tpg
and of course he had like a whole other
leg of his trip planned to this other
island and this amazing hotel
so i decided to just book a room and you
know throw caution into the wind and
i've never been that type of girl like
wanderlust like you're also the type of
person that like when your vacation is
done like you are done and you're ready
to go home so if you weren't ready
then it wasn't your time uh much like
the san francisco 49ers it was not your
time exactly and i actually like to pri
one of my favorite qualities about
myself is like i could be on an amazing
trip
but when the trip is over like i always
really want to go home like i always
miss my home i always miss theo
i don't [ __ ] miss my home anymore
because like i've been there for so long
so i knew theo was in great hands with
his grandparents and i felt like
if not now i had norma in my head norma
was like your 20s after this pandemic is
over when you have the first
opportunity like get the [ __ ] out there
and so i got the [ __ ] out there and i
had the
best second half of the trip i stayed at
the rosewood and i literally called you
the second i got there because
you and zach have to go there like it is
honeymoon central
rosewood on in virgin gorda which is
i've never been to the british virgin
islands
sickening the most it was giving me
turks and caicos maldives vibes
and it's not super easy to get to but
it's not 16 hours to the maldives like
it was gorgeous and it was so unique me
and brian did a patreon episode and you
really spoke about how like this is such
a unique time to travel
and if you can like with
so many people are working remotely now
so you really can travel and if you feel
safe doing it it's super safe
it's so special like i was at this hotel
that was they say they were at 10
capacity
me brian and ben were the only people at
this hotel like it literally felt like
the kids were the campers were like
running the joint
we love to see it it's so unique like i
encourage everyone to safely travel
because like
brian said even on the on the podcast
like in one way or another like change
fees are coming back like all this stuff
we're gonna get back to where we were
before
so if you can just like take a weekend
for yourself road trip
fly somewhere i felt so safe like i
never felt
for one second like i was in like a
situation that i wasn't comfortable with
the bvi's i've had my nose poked and
prodded i think
probably six or eight times in the two
weeks that i was gone because they have
very strict rules so i felt really safe
even though they do the coveted tests a
little different in the bvi like
they choke you to death like in the
airport the second you land in tortola
they test you and i walk out of the
center and i'm like ben like was that
i'm like a baby so i'm like was that
insane he
we come out crying like they just do it
differently in the bvi's but whatever i
got i was allowed to travel so
all in all thank you everyone for giving
me the grace of taking an extra week off
and it was incredible and self-care
self-care is so important except i was
doing a peloton ride and
robin nyc said something like so
profound didn't she just give birth
she just gave birth um and also i've
been back on my peloton grind i'm
finally beating my old record so
like i've gotten to a good place
mentally not like physically really but
i guess that's good though emotionally
is all that matters but she once said in
a ride that really stuck with me
sometimes self-care looks like hard work
not what you were just saying you know
we're like speaking differently
no but like sometimes it does you know
like yeah
well yeah it depends if you're robbing
nyc like of course
like i'm sure robin and i say also like
goes on vacation and chills out but like
sometimes
what you need to do what's best for
yourself is to put in the work okay so
like i'm like hating that you're saying
that because let me tell you why like
i'm the type of person like who unpacks
like the second i get home and of course
i have not unpacked
and it's killing me but like i just
can't like to unpack the memories it'll
be so sad and
i'm just not in the mood and i feel like
in order to feel my best
i i should unpack sometimes self-care
looks like hard work because sometimes
self-care looks like unpacking
it's so unlike me like i'm i literally
like i could get home but the thing is i
think that you've been taking care of
yourself so like if you slip on the
unpacking like it's fine
the scales they balance out like i
literally just want to like hire an
intern to unpack for me like i
so don't want why can't you do it
because he's useless
i missed him so much how's bruiser
you guys knew your stories by the way
sorry to cut you off
like for the thousandth time um your
stories have been
some of your finest work really i keep
responding to everyone else
like i feel like nobody cares about
bruno and his co-host oh i i mean i
don't know about i can't speak for you
know the whole community but people
have critics so if you if you're into it
then i think others are too
hysterical he's doing well like every
day he's getting better his spirits are
coming back but it's like this sense of
betrayal like that he feels i've taken
away his
committed towards him it's really put a
strain on our relationship and i keep
telling him like
brew it will get better like better days
are ahead of you what can i do to make
you feel special like what does brew
want to do
brew needs some self-care brew needs a
vacation what about bro
[Laughter]
and really all he wants is to see
magnolia and theo like and that's all
and he's like i've told you a million
times but can he while he's has stitches
um well knowles has been like busy
theo's been busy so it's like it hasn't
even been an option his stitches seem
like on the mend so as long
i think that in a few days he could see
them but it's like everyone is so busy
theo literally is
back to back back to back to back and
you know what he's doing all day today
meetings meetings meetings meetings
meetings meetings
he's booked and busy no we got to get
the band back together like
now because we were in quarantine for a
week then we had
two weeks off for the trip like it has
been like a full ass month since i've
seen my family
yeah no just so not like us it's so not
like us but it's just a wild few weeks
the parcels would be so upset with us
like i know but you know what i'm sure
like parcells like things have happened
i saw rachel was in hawaii
yeah it looks like a beautiful trip
gotta hit up the montage totally
um also i think we should just talk
about like obviously the elephant in the
room
witches how tan i am there's so many
there's so
well on one right here but how tan i am
like i think we should talk about it i
think it's a beautiful glow
i feel like sickening the sands down
i have like i think i'm gg head like i'm
the most beautiful woman in the world
and i was as i was doing my makeup today
i was like in the vanity being like oh
my god i'm so gorgeous like
it really got to me how like of course a
spray tan is good like nothing compares
to like a true
tan with the freckles and it's like
upsetting that we live in new york and
like this i'll only look like this for
like a few more days
and this only happens like once a year
and it really made me start thinking
like
i think i gotta hit up the uv beds like
i need like a real tan and it's like yes
i could get skin cancer which would not
be good but i would be tan
i think a spray tan will have to suffice
i don't think i think at this point like
the beds we just know too much about
that no and i think our grandfather
would be disappointed in us after all he
did die of
skin cancer right but i think i don't
know
i haven't written it off yet no no but
you should i know but like
how do i get this real looking tan spray
and you know what here's the other thing
if you were to look this tan all the
time then you wouldn't even feel
fabulous anymore
[ __ ] [ __ ] you are so [ __ ] smart so
enjoy it while you have it sickening
let's get a close-up on the tan
but like when it goes away like look at
my chest like hold on and also like we
can't talk about this tan without
talking about the sunburn that you had
to endure
oh my god to get it okay let me tell you
let me tell you
so me and ben the whole trip was
supposed to be one weekend
and i'm like in the british virgin
islands for brian's birthday and i'm
like you know what ben like let's make
the most of it let's go
to like a random other island before and
i always get
a spray tan before a trip if i'm
traveling with other people because you
like to get dressed up whatever
because it makes everything better makes
everything better but if it's like just
me and been on the trip like i don't
give a [ __ ] what i look like
so i was like should i get a spray tan
or should we go to st thomas first
get really tan and show up to like
brian's birthday trip looking sickening
what happened so i'm like that's funny
let's do that
so we get there we only have like two
full days in the sun before we have to
go to brian's
and so i'm making the most and i'm like
not wearing sunblock but i'm like i know
i get a little burn but that's okay
because like
i'll be sickeningly tanned in like no
time
we get back from the beach the first day
and you know you don't realize like how
bad it is until you're
showered and you're inside and i did
look at the uv index um
as i was sitting in the sun for
literally 12 hours
and it said 11. and i don't know why
that seems high i don't even know why i
bothered to look it up because i don't
even know what that means but i
later learned it's the highest one and
we get back and
me and men are tomatoes it's the kind of
sunburn where you're purple
you know i do know this is hurting me it
was so
crazy it like literally ruined like a
huge part of our trip like
we could not sit in the sun for any
other day like i couldn't even take a
bath i want to go to the spa i couldn't
go to the spa
it was crazy we were doing we were so
desperate because like we were planning
on showing up to the party looking
sickening instead you look sick
literally we looked so sick when we
arrived everyone was like
oh my god are you guys you look sick and
we're like trying to play it off we're
like we're
fine like we've just been in the sun a
lot we were dying we couldn't even walk
like
it was literally like robot walking it
was traumatizing so this is your um
sign to wear sunblock and i feel like
because we've not seen the sun for a
year like you do forget how powerful it
can be
and so i think a lot of people will
encounter they'll be so excited for the
sun like so excited to no longer be
green
that they'll get a little carried away
so i'm glad we have this warning
wear sunscreen i know it's like not so
cool to put on sunscreen like while
you're like sunbathing
i know but like it's also not cool to be
purple you should see my back like you
would die
it's literally looks like i don't even
know how to explain it like it's just
skin falling off like in every direction
and it's
so itchy and i can't scratch my back
it's literally like the most it's the
most cruel thing ever like having a
scratch on your back that you can't itch
but imagine having it 24 7. but if i
scratch your back you need to scratch
mine
remember when chris jenner almost um
managed that girl band bg5
yeah i think that she did but she
obviously like would say now that she
didn't
consider it was a huge failure yeah huge
failure not everyone can be little mix
you guys little mix is just
taking over the world does anyone else
feel that way they wake up every day and
it's like little mix just did something
else sickening
no i i don't but i don't doubt that you
feel that but it's also because i
like on peloton i guess like you were in
the bvi's i was on peloton right and
on the peloton like all the instructors
that i ride with have so much respect
for little mix and every single time a
little mix
song comes on they're like little mix
they were on x factor they said girl
bands can't win x factor guess what they
did
they won x factor is pelton big in the
uk maybe
um well one of the instructors that i
ride with is
from the uk but just cody brigby has the
utmost respect for a little mix and
it's a pleasure to ride so i actually
followed cody rigsby on tick tock like
not that i know
anything about his work i've never even
said all i know about like or
all you need to know is that like he
would be your best friend i know and so
like he goes viral on tick tock a lot
like not his videos but people are
always like clipping his like funny [ __ ]
that he says on his ride
and um so i followed him
and good stuff i haven't seen anything
yet like i literally did it yesterday
got it well though that's who i've been
hanging out with um
and sweets and bruno sweets and bruno
sweets every day like a new cone arrives
for him
yeah to um figure out and he's just like
he's like this is better than what i was
working with but still a betrayal
i was like a deadbeat mom i took the
cone off like i know you're not supposed
to but like theo didn't lick his suture
so like he was fine
yeah we got him like this turtleneck um
that's what you had
onesie and it's just a little big i have
like a smaller one coming soon
and unfortunately like we caught him
like licking a little so it had to come
off it was like really sad i was like
you had one job
and it just was to not like yeah but you
can also give him an hour a day without
the cone
um just watch him like yeah yeah so it's
been it's been getting better um
it's just it was tough for for bruno
sweets for the whole wine rib suites
family it really was but i think
eventually it will bring us all together
of course and i'm just glad that now
bruno can safely play in the park
very very true just in time oh
everyone's like coming to new york it's
65 degrees
it's 27 [ __ ] degrees today it's
freezing yeah you guys we had one nice
day like let's not get um carried away
no
that's exactly what people did got
carried the [ __ ] away i know and it's
like even saturday and sunday was like
30s 40s but everyone was treating it
like 60s which was actually nice i
actually had a really fun like
day outdoor day with my friends on
saturday
and it was nice to like have that um
that vibe again
yeah i saw your stories and i'm like oh
homegirl's wearing a fur coat it's not
warm anymore right but it's like i'm
just gonna act like it's warm
but it's not you have to uh
wait hold on um create the weather that
you wish to see in the world yeah dress
for the weather that you wish to see in
the world but then sometimes like if
you're so out of season like you look
like a fool
yeah you everyone everyone has a memory
of like childhood when it's like it
turns out or adulthood yeah right but
like i have a distinct memory it's like
oh
it randomly like became spring like
you're still in your [ __ ] like
long-sleeve turtleneck and it's like the
shame
you never forget incidents like that
ever i remember one
it was in adulthood where it was like
transitioning from um
summer to fall and i just decided that
it was going to be fall today and so
like i got all dressed up for fall and
it was like
so hot you fell into fall and i felt so
stupid
like i'm telling you like it's literally
the most traumatizing
and it's such like a random thing and
everyone's like aren't you hot yes sally
i'm [ __ ] hot i [ __ ] up like why
don't you rub it in
it's really like a traumatizing and
you're right it happens in adulthood but
for me like that traumatizing moment was
100 like in middle school yeah actually
my first
memory like as like if you think of like
the first memory that you
that you have it's hard to really
pinpoint but i just remember like being
in
pre-k and i think the seasons were
changing and it was like that's a really
young memory
no that's what i'm saying i just
remember sitting in
class it was like becoming spring and i
was wearing a dress and i just remember
feeling odd
and feeling like this dress wasn't like
the right thing to be wearing i think
like we were
dressed it was like i was at school
being cute and enrique you are dressed
100 kids wear like onesies i thought no
no like
i was just wearing a cute dress like
that is so and i just remember thinking
like
it's a little hot for this dress like
swamp ass from the dress
i don't remember that but okay wait i
think i remember my first memory
and it involves you obviously obviously
so
i do have a distinct memory of us and
tell me if i'm making this up because
you know and also sometimes memory like
that the idea of memory is just so
complex but also sometimes someone tells
you a story and then you think that it
was your memory
but it's someone telling you the story
literally over this weekend i heard ben
telling someone a story and i literally
turned to him and i'm like
that's my [ __ ] story like that
literally happened to me and i'm like
i i feel like i shouldn't have called
him out because i could kind of
embarrassed him but like
i couldn't hear you are you embarrassing
him i heard him telling this story i'm
like that
lit and it wasn't even that long it was
like one year ago i'm like that's my
[ __ ] story
i think that sometimes memory can like
can do that can
but it's also like a cool story i think
he was just trying to like steal my
story oh
yeah just let him have it but what's
your first memory so we had just had
breakfast and we were getting ready for
school and we started
spinning like oh i know i have this
memory and you eat in your pants yeah
yeah
yeah yeah that's a normal thing to get
ready for school have breakfast and then
start spinning we were like doing like
circles to see who could get the
dizziest and we were laughing so hard
because we're just so funny we knew
somebody in jackie peed and then she
had driven to school separately yeah
because i didn't make the bus because i
peed my pants
um just one more thing i wanted to talk
about that i didn't um
expect to happen you know and i feel
like a lot of more people should be
talking about this because what i really
experienced on my trip like you know
socializing with
not a lot of people of course but just
people for the first time
was my social anxiety
is off the chain like i woke up every
morning being like what did i do last
night and i didn't even do anything
crazy like we sat on the beach like
it's just i didn't expect that to be a
side effect of the pandemic but i just
want to warn everyone like
when you start to slowly like emerge
back into social scenes
with like not your just immediate circle
like i don't give a [ __ ] when my
immediate circle thinks about me like
they're my immediate circle but just
like your
your social it will it will shake you
like
it's not we're not used to it well i
think also social anxiety like that sort
of
what you're describing also comes from
drinking yes like hangover anxiety
yeah but i feel like before the pandemic
like a lot of us had managed like that
that delicate balance of like drinking
having fun and the moral hangover that
comes after it
but i have found that like now being in
social settings like my social skills
are just off
yeah and like people are talking and i'm
like i just don't care what you're
saying
yeah i think i had that before yeah but
and i think i was always awkward
so no you're not awkward you're just
like um not super forward
yeah but i do like i'm i feel hyper
aware of my social skills i'm like
but you know what's cool it's like so
does everyone else like everyone is
just doing their best right like
everyone comes back from the day and
they're like my social sales were weird
not oh jackie's
being weird you know everyone is now
like obsessed with like how weird they
were
yeah how they came off yeah i think
we're fine yeah i think we're fine too
hopefully no everyone's talking about us
um okay i think we should get into
everything because we have a lot to
discuss today and we have a fabulous
interview at the end of the show with
jasmine sanders
aka the golden barbie who is um in this
year's edition of sports illustrated as
she was on the cover last year
and an icon and a queen the episode is
podcast only so if you're watching on
youtube at the end of the episode just
head over the podcast because we
recorded with her via zoom
and she was still looking like
sickeningly stunningly beautiful and
golden
100 um so you think so i think without
further ado it is time for the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
do i sound hoarse you do okay yeah i
don't know why i just like feel horrible
i was actually going to um mention it
but then we just you know went on a
million tangents you're very sticky
shoes today
must stick guys that guy
shows wow that was good yeah um yeah i
don't know why i feel fine but just
okay today's episode is brought to you
by noom think about everything you've
ever learned about getting healthy
there is a lot of contradictory
information out there and things like
that old-fashioned food pyramid aren't
much help
so enter new you know how to chew how to
use chopstick and how to fold a slice of
pizza
but do you really know how to eat noom
says if you want to lose weight it's not
about one thing you ate today
but how you eat in general so nume is
not about what you ate it's about how
you eat
they teach you about your eating your
craving and how to build new habits so
you can ditch your misconceptions and
get smart
about food and the choices that you make
so with noob you can pick the health
goals that are right for you and noon
will personalize a weight loss program
to help your aspirations become a
reality so there's
a million different reasons why you
might want to start eating better
feeling better
a lot of people are doing it to lose
weight to fit better into their clothes
just to feel better physically
um or just feel more confident and
comfortable in a crowd so that's why
nume is so fabulous because it's so
personalized for everyone because it's
based in psychology
they'll teach you why you'd make the
choices that you do and it'll give you
the tools
to replace your habits with healthier
ones noom's cognitive behavioral
approach means you're not just losing
weight but you are building the habits
you need to keep it off
one of the things we love most about
neum is they have like the biggest food
database ever so the app makes it really
easy to track
your food intake and actually when i
went to the gastroenterologist she said
it's probably the best food tracker she
always recommends to her clients it is
the best food tracker
everyone is busy and that's why noon
doesn't demand much of your time they
only ask for 10 minutes a day
and over 80 percent of numerous finish
the program and over 60 percent of them
have stuck with their goal
for at least one year there's a science
to getting healthier and it's called
noom
sign up for your trial today at
n-o-o-m-dot-com
toast learn how to eat again with noom
sign up for your trial today at noom
n-o-o-m-com toast i know jackie's been
on noom for
like almost a year now yeah no it is the
best i recommend it to everyone who's
starting out and doesn't really know
where to start and as far as like the
the cow the food database that they have
like it makes putting in your
intake so easy you don't have to go
searching or like inputting a million
things like
they got your car make it as easy as
possible so if you're ready to learn how
to live healthy or sign up for noom
today at
n o o m dot com slash toast
nice okay first story grammy's
2021 recap we will get to all of the
winners let's talk about the highlights
how much did you watch
i watched pretty much the whole thing
from start to finish um
i was about 20 minutes late but i did
catch up like oh
so but you watch the entire yes okay got
it i
like i was feeling really conflicted
because i know i said i wasn't gonna
watch it but then i was just like
sitting on my bed it was like 7 55
and i was like i'll turn it on just
because like it is the grammys and we do
host
a pop culture show and it seems like the
thing i should watch yes i know that you
and i
we take this like hard stance on award
shows
not always but especially in the last
year because they have a way of feeling
so out of touch in so many ways even
though they spend so much time
like air time during the award show like
talking about the pandemic talking about
the healthcare workers how hard this
year has been
just something about it feels like
people are literally
struggling so hard to put food on the
table i'm like i just don't care that
laura dern is wearing oscar de la renta
like
it i agree like that's what we've been
saying a lot of this year
and i've always like felt um just like
not
the most excited person about award
shows especially this year but i've
always felt like the grammys
if i can watch one it is the grammys
because there's performances and i do
think that like
music is so important especially in
difficult times like i
have turned to music so many times this
year and it's gotten me through a lot of
times so i
i don't want to punish the music no and
i generally feel like
i actually really love music award shows
like i would watch like the people's
music whatever like american music
awards
i just love like i happen to be such a
big fan of so many popular music artists
in pop music in country music so i don't
have that same detest like i look at the
oscars and the golden globes i'm like
you [ __ ] snobs like
i can't relate to these people at all
and i just like i have this like
hatred for everyone who acts i don't
have that for the music industry and i
think it's because first of all
write exactly what you just said even in
the toughest of times
like this year music has been so helpful
like
sad music happy music rain on me
literally save the year like
i don't feel that way about the grammys
and i actually think
part of what's so frustrating about the
golden globes it's the same [ __ ] four
people
every year it's like change it up no and
it's like we spend so much of our year
watching tv and like the things that we
watch aren't being talked like where's
you know real housewives of new york on
the golden globes red carpet 100
so i feel like music really nails it's
so diverse in its
genres and it's people there's so many
different artists there's latin art
like there's just so much and it feels
really representative of the world we
live in whereas like the golden globes
i'm like
what worlds are you guys living in yes i
totally agree so
for that reason i gave the grammys a
chance um i watched the opening like the
first
chunk until commercials i think and
there was performances by harry styles
billy eilish and heim um and i just like
don't want to be super negative
no that's okay that's usually my job and
i'm going to be positive so let's switch
it up but
then i had to turn it off yeah and then
uh zach was watching it so i caught
um i caught the baby bruno mars taylor
swift and dewalippa and i loved all four
of those performances and i was like i'm
leaving on a high
so overall i'm like neutral and then i
heard really good things about like the
rest of the show i just felt like the
opening was like a really
bad start let's just start from the top
like let's go through all the
performances and then
all the winners harry styles okay i know
we were talking about this before you
said it felt like a cover band
no oh so i think harry styles is beyond
fabulous so talented absolutely love
his music love the song watermelon sugar
who doesn't i felt like the performance
was like kind of lackluster
it felt like someone doing like a talent
show at high school
doing a really good job but like that's
how we're gonna open the grammys i just
wasn't
i wasn't totally impressed no i couldn't
disagree last like the lack of shirt i
don't know like how you could say that
was
talent show and the boa and the like it
was
it was gorgeous like i don't think i've
ever seen harry styles belly like it was
everything
and he literally said i want your belly
and then his belly was out like that is
[ __ ]
lyrical artistry genius is it
yes yes it is okay
agree to disagree okay but i'm with you
on hame like that was i thought it was a
a really good placement like you know
what i mean like that's a great time
slot
and i think i've said this before i
should adore hayden and i just don't
friends of taylor swift
jewish sisters like oh my god us like
no no not except that one song that they
first
the wire love that song yep
they haven't done for me since then um
and i did like their coordinating prada
outfits but i'm like they're just so
like quirky you know
and i'm like it just wasn't for me it
was not for me and billy eilish was in
between harry styles and haim
and the thing is is that i just don't
think i am meant
to be like billy eilish's number one fan
in terms of like my demographic
i think she speaks for a lot of young
people um
i respect her a lot and i think she's
extremely talented
but she's just not my personal vibe is
that i say yeah i think that's fair to
say okay
okay so then what happened after can we
just get a list of the performers so we
could just like
compliment because the best ones were do
alipa like oh my god
what a star star every time i see her
perform
i'm reminded of like how incredibly
talented she is her music is not only
stellar like she's literally
if she tried desperately to release a
bad song she couldn't
but when she performs she comes to life
she's such a good dancer she's such a
good live performer her voice is so good
her outfits were so sick and chris
appleton did her hair and you could just
tell like her hair was sickening
her red carpet cher butterfly
she got a 10 out of 10 on every level
and as the awards went by like she kept
not winning them
and i was surprised she did end up
winning one and i was happy for her i
was happy for her too cody breaks me
really campaign for her to win album of
the year
it wasn't gonna happen i know but
i think she had like a really good
chance and i would have been happy if
she had won i'm obviously so happy
that taylor won there was literally no
way that any other album and i'm not
just like a delusional tailor
even though i absolutely lived for dua
lipa's music this year and like
some like physical and don't start now
were some of the best songs of all time
yeah
i actually don't think i ever listen
actually let me like once or twice i
listen to future nostalgia from start to
finish
and like yeah but that was it no and
it's like but i listened to
folklore from start to finish all the
countless times i did it this morning
while doing my hair and makeup like
and i think that it's just and i'm not
just saying this as a delusional taylor
swift fan which i
am i'm not denying that but i think so
many people whether they're taylor swift
fans or not like
leaned on that album so heavily like it
came out at the worst time
for everyone like for whatever different
reason whether you were struggling like
emotionally financially mentally like
that album literally like
cured coronavirus like it just it didn't
cure chronic it cured quarantine like it
made quarantined bearable it gave us
something to live for
and not to put down any of the other
albums but like album of the year
represents the year yeah folklore was
this year i
i'm not arguing with you just in case
anyone cody didn't understand cody would
and it was a good album not putting it
down i don't think cody loves taylor
swift but also they don't play taylor
swift on peloton i don't think he
relates to her music so we'll never he
he's never had to discuss it we'll find
out we'll find out okay
black pumas performed doja cat um jojo
cat's outfit was really really brave
yeah no it wasn't good but her
performance she always um impresses me
i'm like oh yeah she is really good
because like
her music is good but she's like a
dually but like the singing the dancing
on fleek like she was great
yeah post malone um i love post malone
and just like
the the fact that there was a very small
gathering of people on that roof kind of
how they did at the cmas and we kept
getting
panned to people who were just like
watching the performances which is my
favorite part of award shows
was great he was giving me like the best
reactions to other people's performances
and his performance was excellent too
and i feel like i know she's
um like not technically single but i
think him and cardi
b would be a really cute couple oh cute
also when they had like their little you
know gym
auditorium of performances and you saw
like the other people
in the background um it was an
interesting
i loved it addition yeah it's just like
they had to be on the whole time right
which is hard
yeah uh megan stallion okay unbelievable
like
unbelievable like nobody worked harder
at the grammys than meghan's stallion
like
nobody it was such a good performance
and then mccarty came out in that big
bed it was
everything everything okay i have to
watch that one
oh you didn't see it oh no i didn't see
it i said the ones that i did see it was
so sickening like
literally just they were working and
they did [ __ ] they did body adiati
they did uh a little i think they did a
little savage it was like a medley
it was unbelievable and they had this
huge bed constructed and it was just
like so sickening
and then like trevor noah came out and
like was making really bad jokes and i
have something to say about trevor noah
i've seen a lot of people critiquing him
and he started to annoy me and then it
occurred to me it's like even the best
hosts in the world
always becomes annoying at some point in
the night and i actually think trevor
noah like did a really good job of
keeping the annoyances
down to the minimum but his peak
annoying was when he came out on stage
like to cardi b
when she was done and like being like
this is my dream like he was being
so annoying i'm like trevor like just
cut to commercial yeah
okay that's fair um john mayer and marin
morris
it was really cute i loved it i was
waiting for john mayer to um
sing but he just played guitar which
like we love but like come on
oh i didn't realize okay so let me know
what that sounds like
um taylor swift
there's so much to unpack first of all
let's talk let's start with the song
selects
we got um cardi cardigan which isn't my
favorite song but
i think it really showcases how talented
taylor is in terms of like
lyrical i knew you'd haunt all of my
what-ifs like just like all these
beautiful
soliloquies then she gets up off the
grass
and she's sitting on top of a house and
she sings august which
of the two albums she released this year
i would say august is probably my
favorite song
and the fact that she's peace oh let's
see
i don't want to listen to peace just
like anywhere like i would listen to
august like
on a plane a train an auto like i would
listen peace is reserved
so august yes i stand by what i said
august is so good and the fact that she
played it means like she knows that it's
like
you know my song then i'm like oh wow
that was so great
then she goes into an evermore song
willow which is
my [ __ ] favorite song on that album
and aaron destner the lights come on
aaron destner jack antonoff they're in
front she's with her dress
it you realize like the house they're in
really i think it was meant to resemble
lily pond studios
yeah it was um i don't think it was lily
pond
pond pond
pondery blade taylor swift pond
long pond studios okay it was really
close um and it was just like
beautifully metaphorical and wonderful
and she looked gorgeous
and the songs were gorgeous she sounded
gorgeous it was a 10 out of [ __ ] 10.
yes i loved the set looked like a
storybook i felt like that was a great
use
of you know the auditorium situation and
it was
it was clear that it could be done yeah
it could be done um
also before her was bruno mars
and anderson park still sonic now that
that was my number one performance of
the night it was stellar
it was so [ __ ] good that song we
haven't had a chance to recap the first
song that
came out leave the door open and it's so
amazing
it's he just nails that aesthetic like
he has
this idea and the way that it comes to
life i knew
like with the outfits and the dancers
and the microphones and the song it was
just really so like
beautifully disco-y yes i love him so
good i'm
so excited for the album they're putting
out and it was such a treat to like have
him back
on the grammy stage like in the mix
where he should be
where he should be he took a break i'm
happy for him sometimes self-care looks
like taking a break
but sometimes it looks like coming back
to the grammys and giving the people
what they want i couldn't agree more
so well said um de baby and roddy rich
okay
unbelievable unbelievable when those old
women
like who were in the choir were like
acquiring like making gossip it was soap
but also like dancing
yes they were giving me life i thought
it was such an
interesting way to perform a song that
we've heard
so many times and i had so much respect
for the ingenuity like
he just he literally turned a rap song
into like a a gospel soul song it was so
genius i loved it yeah did justin bieber
perform
no no i'm going through the list of
nominees did lady gaga or
anna grande no beyonce no no but
she gave us so much life in oh oh i
forgot you to watch okay
so her and megan the stallion won i
forget what the category was but
obviously
hips tick tock why not dance that song
yes of course and
like beyonce let meg like make the whole
speech megan was like
freaking out that she was on stage with
beyonce and
as uh this as she was
like the stage was ending trevor noah of
course like pops in
and he's like by the way like history
has just been made um
beyonce is now tied with uh he didn't
say who it was but i read up it's alison
krause
um for the most female awarded grammy
artist
of all time which was like crazy but it
did give me like a little flashback to
like
kanye vma like because it was like
really like meg's moment and beyonce was
like really letting mag have the moment
like beyonce said two words at the end
and beyonce felt like she made the same
face that she made like when kanye
interrupted taylor swift at the vmas but
it ended up being fine i think maybe i
was only when i felt that way
and then beyonce won another um
award like two seconds later thus making
her
they said on air the most awarded artist
and then i saw the recording academy on
twitter like kind of clarified
female artist oh i was seeing most
awarded artists that's what they said on
the tv
that's right i was confused okay still
amazing no it was cool to watch in real
time
and megan the stallion and beyonce's i
would encourage you to watch on youtube
like
this the two of them standing there like
megan and sally and like freaking the
[ __ ] out she's like
when i grew up like everyone around me
and i was like all i wanted to be was
beyonce and like i literally became the
ratchet beyonce and it's like been the
biggest dream of my life
it was just like a great moment for
women wow that's amazing okay i'm gonna
go through all the winners now
share your thoughts if you have any i
pretty much thought i pretty much agreed
with all the winners like
okay record of the year was billy eilish
everything i wanted except that one i'm
gonna disagree
yeah um album of the year folklore
taylor swift
i heard like you really weren't feeling
that one no i was i mean i just like
knew it you know it's hard being like
raven simone no and i'm i'm so
happy for taylor especially after like
having watched miss americana and the
snub for reputation we know how
important it is to her when she was
singing in her song
like um i come back stronger than a 90s
trend i felt like she was talking to the
grammys yeah and when she made her
speech she was like
thank you so much i'll never forget that
you did this for me like she
certain artists don't care about the
grammys taylor has made it very very
clear like album of the year just the
grammys in general is something she
really um values
yeah song of the year was i can't
breathe by her
yes best new artist megan stallion i
agree with but who else was nominated
um a lot of nominees ingrid andres
phoebe bridgers
chica noah cyrus d smoke jojo cat
katrinata i think megan the stallion
is the clear winner now i'm remembering
when i found out noah cyrus is nominated
in the same category as megan stallion
and i was like pretty much shook and i'm
just feeling that all over again
yes best music video brown skin girl
beyonce blue ivy carter and whiz kid oh
yes blue ivy
now has a gray happy for her best pop do
ogre performance
rain on me lady gaga and ariana grande
100 well-deserved
best pop solo performance watermelon
sugar harry styles which i think is a
big deal like considering when you
remember like harry styles
came from one direction a band whose
music was very popular but never grammys
no and like considering all the other
songs nominated too in that category it
was a hard category
it was how was bts's performance that's
something i have to
they sang dynamite they literally the
grammys like
uses bts for ratings because it was the
last thing it was after album of the
year always do that oh every award show
uses bts
but my god i was like
it was so good and i was like dancing in
my bed and ben was like trying to go to
sleep
and i was just trying to explain to him
like the production value and like these
kids like
the dancing was it was better it was the
same
it's like all their performances like
this one wasn't any different but it was
just like
10 out of 10 dances no it's like 10. it
doesn't if it ain't broke don't fix it
and it was like gorgeous you know
hollywood lights like i don't i think
they were in
korea yeah they were in seoul yeah but
it was still like they were on top of
they were like in a studio and then they
walk up the stairs and they're like on
top of a building there's like fireworks
it was just hollywood glamour like five
stars they are really
showman and these days we don't get that
a lot
a lot of things are like stripped down
they reminded me as i was watching them
like they are like bruno mars like
the way they have this like pro they
make
like the the the show like a priority
like yes
their show elements showman yeah they
are the greatest showmen
they are the greatest showman and i was
actually really surprised that dynamite
did not win anything like it really was
like
a song of the year i agree and i think
it's really hurtful
i agree and the bts army was [ __ ]
twisted up on twitter
i know because they were so excited that
they were nominated and it was a big
deal for them to be nominated but i do
think that dynamite like is one of those
songs that
cured the year it reminds me of like and
i keep i don't know why i keep comparing
them to bruno mars but it was like a 24
carat magic like
it was just song that just like snuck up
and i said it was like damn this song is
so
[ __ ] good yes agreed best pop vocal
album went to future nostalgia
by dua lipa and i feel as though she
deserved that in the pop category
yes i agree and also feels like for a
lot of these people who are nominated in
many categories won at least
yes i don't know anyone that didn't win
anything except
hame i think and did justin bieber win
anything no but he also like denounced
the grammys on his story remember
that's true and also they announced so
many before the show and
oh he won with jan and shay for ten
thousand hours that i feel as though
it's deserved
i love that song um yeah and then all of
the different
genres rock country etc um yeah the
country um
category i thought was really really
interesting miranda lambert won
and i do feel i've made like such a 180
on miranda lambert like i respect the
[ __ ] out of her
and her album wild card is so good and i
thought she deserved to win even though
i was really gunning for ashley mcbride
because i love her so much
but you know it was all women in the
category i know i know it's so
interesting
sorry to cut you off again um
i feel like in country award shows like
the men are always winning
and it's like the jason aldean luke
bryan like they're
kind of like they all do the same thing
i don't include luke comes in that kind
of category i think he's a really unique
artist but like
the big like jason aldean luke bryan
blake shelton like they all have the
same three songs and they like share
them and it's like not real music
and i think they are always like winning
whereas like the women in country music
like are putting out like
heartfelt lyrical masterpieces and i'm
so glad the grammys respected
the women in country because in my
opinion they released better music
yeah i think i think that's a really
good point i think miranda lambert i'm
so happy that she won
i think her album was great my personal
country album of the year though was
ingrid andrews me too but i
no actually i stand by ashley mcbride i
know i'm new on the ashley mcbride
ship but like we are fully built ready
to go love to see it
love to see a new ship speaking of ships
let's segue into our next story
a little relationship news very
confusing on friday page six announced
that jlo and a-rod broke off the
engagement
and then um everyone else said no they
didn't and now jayla and a-rod are
saying
no we didn't they're saying we're
working through stuff yeah they say they
love each other and want to work on
their relationship a-rod told tmz that
he is not single and
j-lo put out a tick-tock video that was
so sickening did you see the video
okay she put out a tick tock that um
it's all about like her being fabulous
like montage sort of
and it references the split she posts
all the headlines and then was like
said something what did she say
something like oh wow good for her i
live for a tick-tock clarification
yeah she just watch it she debunked
good for her i actually um just recently
followed j-lo on tick-tock so i'm
actually
surprised i didn't see her content yeah
it's a really good tick tock video and
she's also letting us know and
i don't know i mean when we heard the
news that they were splitsville
okay hear it oh she's gonna watch the
video this
yes oh wow
she's such a queen i don't want to get
demonetized but
love that for her yes so they're still
together apparently
um they obviously have problems like
we've all been alive and well in the
last six months like there's a lot going
on there
there is a lot going on so just madison
lacroix like taking down a
like a hollywood couple i was like ready
for it to be over for them and
i because i just think he's so unworthy
i agree
um but now they're still together so
never mind i'm like upset by this whole
thing because i think of them as a
couple i was so
invested in like i thought that these
two people like the fact that they
haven't been married for 50 years like
makes no sense like
they're perfect for each other in a
million different ways and then over the
last year i've just heard all these
things about him like [ __ ] around on
jlo
obviously the madison lacroix one is
very public but there's a couple
headlines like random playmates
different models coming out saying they
facetime they like have phone sex with
him
and i'm like you're really gonna
disrespect j-lo like that like who the
[ __ ] do you think you are like
are you kidding i'm just it's disgusting
it is she's everything of the sort and i
feel like the events of the last few
months have made me realize like he's
kind of
nothing of the sort no i went from like
idolizing him as like an athlete a
businessman
and as a businessman bow to literally
like thinking so low of him like you're
gonna [ __ ] around on
jlo like who on god's green diddly dally
earth do you think you are
yeah to [ __ ] around on jlo that's just
not it no it's not it and so
who knows how what happens from here but
they're together
so we'll respect it i do feel like it's
probably like the beginning of the end
yeah but i don't know i feel like why
would she
renege like why she's like because once
it's over like everyone's gonna take her
side obviously
it takes time maybe they're not like
officially over right now but like this
is the first break and i think it's just
the beginning
they could possibly still be together
but like an independent fierce woman
like jlo like she just can't get over
things like this like
it's it's unforgivable i agree
so there's nothing to say anymore the
story was they broke up and then the
story was said they didn't
yeah this is giving me like um lily
reinhardt cole sprouse vibes like
everyone reported that they broke up and
then they literally tweeted like no we
didn't but then eventually they did
see yeah okay our next story back
to award shows the oscar nominations are
here they were announced by nick jonas
and priyanka chopra
see this is actually like what makes me
roll my eyes like the oscars
yes so let's just go through the big
categories if you feel strongly
or want to make a prediction let me know
i've only seen i think
for movies that are oscar where they've
only seen promising young women which
was
excellent oh was it yeah well it's
nominated for best picture along with no
mad land which from what i've heard
is like a best picture okay um the trial
of the chicago seven also heard really
good things
minari sound of metal the father judas
and the black messiah and mink
i heard judas in the black messiah was
fire actress in a leading role
francis mcdormand no madlan vanessa
kirby pieces of a woman
carrie mulligan promising young woman oh
i didn't realize that she was in it and
you were still able to watch it okay so
did we talk about it on the podcast i
don't think so i think we did i think
actually you might be having amnesia
because i said
she like looked so weird in the movie
like because
what do you think when you think of
harry mulligan what do you think daisy
great gatsby yeah she looks like britney
spears like the whole movie she had like
a
long blonde hair and like like just
couldn't see her as any like it was so
confusing to watch her
but she was very good um okay that's
good to know viola davis marines black
bottom and andre day the united states
versus
billie holliday andre day is a shoe-in
in my opinion and then actor in a
leading role chadwick boseman is
nominated for mourinho's black bottom
anthony hopkins the father is ahmed
sound of metal
gary oldman bank steve yoon minari
um that'd be like really beautiful if
chadwick bozeman won
yeah that would be really beautiful a
posthumous um award
yeah actress in a supporting role are
you
still interested oh i'm not paying
attention anymore i know i just
i just haven't heard of any of you guys
i really haven't seen or even some of
the
some of them i heard of didn't see some
of them i have not heard of know me too
so i think and that's crazy because like
we literally
talk about pop culture full-time that's
just what i'm saying like these movies
like
movies used to be like do you remember
the year when like dude there used to be
a time when like you would see
maybe it's because theaters like aren't
open this year but where you would see
like five out of five like you saw
slumdog millionaire like you saw
all of that but also it's like theaters
weren't open this year but we all spent
the whole year
watching movies and television from home
so
i don't know i guess like trolls didn't
get nominated i guess it was the movie
of the year
i guess it didn't i guess the holiday
didn't get nominated i guess the king of
staten island didn't either which is
shocking um the only other category that
i i'm always interested is the original
song
oh yeah me too um hussevik from
eurovision song contest
oh actually i do believe i came on here
and like
ripped to shreds that movie eurovision
you did it was
a piece of [ __ ] but
the music was [ __ ] amazing okay like
so i was shocked okay that's that's
positive
yeah also fight for you from judas and
the black messiah
low c from the life ahead speak now
by taylor swift from one night in miami
and hear my voice from the trial of the
chicago seven yeah
it the first time in a while that a
animated movie song didn't get
nominated i'm gonna listen to the music
because i actually
enjoy that yeah that's always one of my
um personal favorite categories did you
say cynthia revo is one of the singers
oh i didn't say who sings the songs are
sure i thought you just said that i said
the movie it's from oh well if cynthia
revo was going to perform like then i'll
turn it i'm tuned into the oscars
because she's
something to say yes when are the oscars
who cares i guess i would be on the ipad
i would know april 25th
i would just like to know if like our
listeners like do you also hate the
oscars
you know what that is such a great
question like do you want us
to be watching these things is it is it
important to you because like i'll do it
for you but just y'all like i would
literally rather
die than watch the oscars this year i
agree like i will do it if everyone says
please we need your recap like
i will do it that's what we do but if
you guys feel as we do and like we just
don't care about these things right now
let us know yeah i've just never really
like i think just over the last few
years i've just become like
over movies i know that sounds crazy i'm
just so much more of like a tv show
girly now
because it used to be like movies were
so much better than tv now it's like
tv is where you want to be and also like
to be
in a show or a limited series on a
streaming service like is extremely
prestigious yeah it used to be like no
one wanted to be on tv
right it was like the small screen yeah
but when everything is on your tv at
home it's all the same and also like the
doing a series like i think of like
queen's gambit like that is a movie that
was done episodically
right i wouldn't be surprised if like in
a few years like leonardo dicaprio does
like a
short series mini series on netflix like
it's prestigious now and it's the golden
globes for me like i don't live for but
they
are to me a little bit more my speed
because they include television yeah
i agree i just think that the way it's
categorized is starting to become
outdated considering everything that we
watch is like even if it's like a series
that has three parts all that's a show
that's not a movie but like
we're not we're not in these boxes
anymore no and honestly like
the queen's gambit is the perfect
example because for me that was like the
most
amazing thing that came out this year
and it won't win an oscar because it's
not a movie
right technically but it's oscar worthy
i completely agree yeah they should
really change their rules
i think that at one day they're going to
because times are changing times are
changing
i agree okay speaking of change chris
harrison
speaking of change um is it the chris
harrison story
that happens to be brought to you by
legacy box yes
wow that's a huge i'm so glad you got
that in
legacy box is a super simple mail-in
service to have all your home movies and
pictures digitally preserved on a thumb
drive dvd or the cloud so if you're the
type of person who has like a storage
box
full of old cassettes vcr we had
so many vhs's growing up and when you
want to go
find them and watch them it's nearly
impossible but legacy box
is the best service they literally send
you a box and a label to ship in
all your whatever it is cassettes your
bar mitzvah your wedding anything that
you can't access anymore and they will
digitize it for you
um we've used it it's such a fabulous
service it's literally the best idea
it's one of those companies where i'm
like i should have come up with that
legacy box is a way for you to easily
and affordably digitally preserve your
past
the process from start to finish is so
easy you pack and send your items their
team will digitize
everything by hand and then you enjoy
and you'll get back perfectly preserved
digital copies on thumb drive dvd or the
cloud
it'll be ready to watch and share and
enjoy plus
while they are processing it they will
keep you up to date with regular emails
throughout the process
legacy box is the world's largest
digitizer of home movies and photos and
has helped over a million families
digitally preserve their past so
obviously this is great for anyone who
has a lot of those old movies but
it's great for like a mom or a grandma a
gift i think it's it'll
be really sweet for someone's birthday
so if you want to get started preserving
your past
do that today at legacybox.com toast and
you can get an incredible 50
off your first order when you use that
link legacybox.com toast
today to take advantage of this
exclusive offer today but you can send
it in whenever you're ready if you go to
legacybox.com
slash toast and save 50 while supplies
last
great so speaking of change chris
harrison has been replaced on the
bachelorette by tasha adams and caitlin
bristow
warner horizon and abc entertainment
told page six in a statement on friday
that caitlyn bristow and tasha adams
will co-host the next season of the
bachelorette
quote chris harrison will not be hosting
the next season of the bachelorette we
support chris and the work that he is
committed to doing
in his absence former bachelorettes
tasha adams and caitlin bristow will
support the new bachelorette
through next season i mean that's crazy
like
i think that when when he had stepped
back i thought it was just
like you know like
just to like calm people down and
thought maybe it would blow over by the
time the new season was ready to start
but people are really really [ __ ]
unhappy with chris harrison and i think
that
people are going to be very pleased with
tasha and chris i mean
and caitlyn and i think that's actually
like such an honor for tasha and caitlin
yes definitely it's still unclear like
what's gonna happen
after this season of the bachelorette
like for next bachelor i
it's possible that chris comes back or
do they bring in two former
bachelor contestants who are men to
support the male league or maybe like
caitlyn and tasha are so universally
beloved like this becomes they're the
new chris
so maybe it's a trial but also and i'm
so excited for it to be caitlyn and tish
i think both of them are perfect choices
but like the fact that it
it like it takes two women to do the job
that they weren't that hard
no but like why couldn't i i mean i'm
happy to have both of them
like why does it take two of them yeah
if chris harrison could do it alone
i know and also like i mean i think i
can at least speak for caitlyn caitlin
is a professional host like she hosts
her own podcast it's
super successful i don't think there's a
doubt that she could do the job
or tasha right but when i first read
this statement it didn't they
maybe it's just the way that they framed
it they'll be there to support the lead
like they'll
have like girl chats and stuff and like
off camera not necessarily like be
hosting like are they going to come in
and say this is the final rose like we
[ __ ]
know it's the final road so maybe well
that's true like chris harrison's job
like
like the show could go on without it
it's like thank you chris harrison we
know how to count
yeah um and actually that's a good point
kind of how like jojo did
when she filled in for chris harrison
yes she was there like for emotional
support but she didn't pop in and be
like this is the final rose because like
it's literally self-explanatory right so
i think maybe that will just
go regardless but i think it will it
i don't know if they're stepping into
chris harrison's shoes exactly or
they're gonna change up the format of
like what it means to be the host of the
show
which i'm just like here for in general
yeah i mean i'm intrigued because i
love caitlyn and i love tasha
but i do feel like and i know i've i
sound like a broken record i've said
this a hundred times
i do believe after tonight like i'm done
yeah
it's been a journey tonight is the is
tonight is the final rose you guys
and it's the finale and after the final
rose tonight right yes but i'll tell you
who's happy about this
the trucker's flirtation yeah they are
going ham you guys they've lost their
minds
they're so excited and i'm excited for
them me too
um i'm just like i fee maybe i'm curious
if other people feel this way like i'm
so fatigued
by the bachelor franchise just like
they've really put us through a lot this
year i'm like i'm just kind of over it
i'm really curious to see how this
season ends up now i feel like we
finally caught up
with real life like watching these dates
that i know were filmed six months ago
when so much has happened in the last
month
so i'm looking forward to tonight seeing
like i do believe rachel wins
i do believe
maybe they are still together i don't
know how they could be after all this
but i'm curious to get an update and to
actually hear from rachel connell
but after that like i think i'm just
done like it's so exhausting
i think a lot of people feel that way
okay so
that's okay and we'll see do they
announce a new bachelorette tonight
in past they have because usually the
bachelorette starts filming in like four
days from
after the final rose i heard a spoiler
so i heard a spoiler too and based on
the spoiler that i heard
um you won't be watching i read
okay fifth and final story just a little
streaming news
disney plus is popping off and it is
forecast to steal netflix's crown as the
world's biggest streaming firm
wow by 2024. so that's just a little
caveat okay and also like who knows what
could happen like
so much can happen like we literally who
thought the pandemic was gonna happen
you know right
netflix is forecast to lose its crown as
the world's biggest video streaming
provider within three years maybe that's
why netflix is now like cracking down we
reported last week
on shared family accounts like you have
to start using your own account
yes amid explosive growth at disney
after the launch of its rival on demand
service only 16 months ago
so we have spent a lot of time here at
morning toast chronicling the streaming
wars
the successes disney plus the failures
quibby yes
and i think that this is an interesting
update though like a lot needs to happen
in the next three years for this to take
hold
but it's nice to know that disney plus
is doing so well yeah i mean disney plus
is actually killing it and
when you think disney plus i'm like oh
yeah it's great for kids and it's great
for like adults who want to watch old
episodes of hannah montana
but it's actually really kind of nailing
it in the music space like with black as
king
um long pond studios like
they're kind of like hitting a bunch of
other categories like i didn't see them
succeeding in
and stealing like netflix did a few
music specials like ben platt and
whatever
but they're kind of like killing it in
places i didn't think they would kill it
in
like obviously like cartoons interesting
also i think that like the mandalorian i
know we don't watch that
like baby yoda is so massive for them
um and they had a really like a bunch of
really good premieres baby yoda
is so cute camper he's camper i kind of
want to like kiss him
no everybody loves baby yoda and i've
never i don't think i'll ever watch the
mandolin i mean
no i i know that i want some definition
something would have to go very wrong
for me to start watching the mandalorian
but i think baby yoda is someone we can
all get behind
i actually think he's like a camper at
heart and he's so [ __ ] cute he's so
cute he needs to be counseled
i don't know anything about like what is
a mandalorian what is the tv show about
all i know is like baby oda is
so cute so cute um here's what i think i
know and it makes sense based on the
fact that yoda is a baby
actually don't want to know it's a
prequel to star wars so like yoda in the
star wars
is i think he's fully rise yeah in the
prequel he's a bebe
oh that's cute yeah i think that's the
concept okay well happy for disney
plus keep killing it maybe we can get
like an ever more long pawn studios i
don't know just an idea
throwing it out there mm-hmm maybe we
could like they actually dead ass stole
taylor swift and beyonce from netflix
homecoming was on ethics miss americano
was on netflix reputation was on their
flight
i guess they're just paying big bucks to
huge stars and it's working that's so
true and i just wanted to get your
thoughts on one more thing because
taylor announced that lover fest is
cancelled it's not happening
um i think that makes a lot of sense
considering she's put out like two whole
new albums since
and lover like we're done like lover who
yeah we're like done with her i
just assumed it would be cancelled like
this is not news to me right no that
wasn't my
next question which was like so what do
you think she's gonna do next
considering she had this like plan for a
festival
i feel like evermore and folk more like
could be a very like fall
harvest festival yeah no i did i
definitely think we're gonna we're gonna
skip over the lover era
and do like a folklore ever more i don't
know if it'll be like another festival
or a concert a tour i think part of the
reason why she was doing lover fest was
back then which was literally like two
years ago now um she was going through a
lot and like could not
she was fatigued she was fatigued and
also i think her mom's health was
um her i think her cancer had made a
return so i think she didn't want to
spend time away from her mom
but you know that was a while ago like
maybe things have changed maybe she can
go on tour now yeah that's a good point
so i would like maybe she's
looking forward to tour life i would
live for like an ever more folklore like
somber ass like bony bear type
like cry fest yeah i think that's what
you might be getting but i also like
she does stadiums and i don't know i
feel like that like concrete isn't the
vibe and i would like a grassy knoll i
know but
the thing is say what you want about
taylor swift whether you like love her
or hate her
she knows how to put on a show a showman
she is like a definition of like her
concerts are
experiences so i think even if it is
like a more low keyboard
she will make it a sensation she'll
cultivate the vibe but that's like how i
felt when i saw ed sheeran like a man in
his guitar
at metlife stadium like give me a light
or something like there was nothing it
was so boring
and i like ed sheeran but his concert
was not it yeah i think that she'll
definitely get creative
considering the vibe of folklore and
evermore she'll cultivate that vibe
yeah it'll be good i agree and i'm like
i love her like that little trio of
aaron desner he's like so cute i don't
know if he's ever won a grammy before
but he was just like so excited
and like jack anderson off i feel like
has won a million grammys because he
produces so many popular albums
and he didn't even say anything but
taylor let aaron destroy speak first and
he was just like so excited
like thinking his brother and [ __ ] like
i was living for it oh that's really
cute
yeah okay well those are the past five
stories i feel as though you needed to
know them
um i did not watch real housewives of
atlanta because i was watching the
grammys but you did watch i did watch
the last two episodes we haven't
recapped yet it's the fallout from the
bachelorette you see
um the story make its way to page six
and in the blogs
and everyone's speculating on i mean
there's not even anything to speculate
like it was kenya
she hasn't like admitted it but all the
girls agree yeah
it's not like a huge um point it's just
like it was kind of
fact you know and it's like we're not
even gonna debate it um
and i feel like for kenya she was trying
to you know
get porsha to engage in this
conversation and porsha's
porsche's strategy at the end of the
party and and going forward has just
been to like not even respond to kenya
it's not
that didn't work for kenya so ken you
took it to the press to a place
so that porsha had to address it at some
point she still
hasn't really there was a it's nobody's
[ __ ] business the cameras were off
she's a single woman leave her alone i
so agree
kenya just is so on this
and then the episode that aired last
night was 10 10 20
cynthia and mike's wedding which was so
stunning
it was really crazy to watch her wedding
like given
like i just kept thinking back to her
wedding to peter which we watched when
it aired
and the vibe was just completely
different and like the way that her
sister is just like so here like they're
in this together versus like remember at
this year
they stole the license so it's just like
it's
shared the two of them and it was so
nice to watch and see and she talks
about like getting flack for having a
wedding during a pandemic i guess wendy
williams had really like gone
in on her at the time and it was like
having
watching it then it's like given what we
know everything about this year it's
like
the wedding just felt even more special
that it was like a celebration of such
love and like people coming together
yeah i'm not the type of person who's
gonna shame like
if someone invites you to a wedding i'm
not gonna disagree with them if i feel
safe i'll go if i don't feel safe i
won't go everyone is we live in a free
country do what you want
um but i do think it's interesting how
like at the and i was surprised because
i know kelly doug is problematic as [ __ ]
but i was actually surprised she didn't
have like a full out wedding like with
like 300 people
she had a 20 person wedding and like
they were giving her [ __ ] at the reunion
so
i'm like i fear for cynthia like what
they're going to say at the reunion and
there was like a hurricane coming
through
so they had to move the ceremony indoors
so it would have been an outdoor wedding
but it was an indoor wedding there was a
lot of people like
i'm sure it will come up at 3 union but
i was just really happy for cynthia
i know um and she's just had like such a
long journey and like i do feel like
chill is forever forever so
i love him it was so it was such a
beautiful thing to behold
and there weren't cameras in they didn't
go into the wedding it was people's like
home
uh iphones and also cynthia's like
photography
videographer footage which was also kind
of nice because i do feel like sometimes
when the cameras are there they drag
everything out
but so instead it was just like these
are the need to know moments yeah well
i felt it felt more intimate i actually
have been to a televised wedding britney
and jax
and i have to say there was like a full
camera crew there and i feel like they
did a really good job of like they
looked like just regular videographers
for weddings
they didn't drag stuff out like everyone
was just like i actually had a lot of
respect for like how much they didn't
torture jackson brittany to like get
certain footage
yeah no but i'm saying like from the
viewer perspective when they when they
have all this footage they air all of it
sometimes it's even a special and it's
like
there's not that much that i care to see
i just want to see the major moments and
so
it would it we were able to be there
without being bored by it and so we saw
the very special moments and i and i
i loved being able to watch it so um
that's nice it was really nice but the
night before the wedding um they
had um a party for the nieces because i
guess
uh candy and kenya are bridesmaids so
they were with
um cynthia the night before so the
aunties were away the aunties were away
the nieces will play
and it was just like crazy um it
actually was such a fun looking night
but toyah is just
so wishy-washy is she watching two faces
you have to watch the scene it's like
what are you trying to say like it's
like she just says a million things in
whichever one like
someone's gonna agree like that's the
road she would go down right but what
does she
actually stand for i don't know right
because when she was like finally seeing
like who kenny really was in south
carolina i thought she had finally like
turned to the good side
and then she goes to kenny's photo shoot
and it's like apologizing i'm like no
you were right
yeah i i agree so frustrating yeah and
then she like starts to air
kenya's some of her stuff with um her
husband
and even the other girls like porsha's
like that's not your place to be telling
us this
no so it's like she has no extreme one
way and extremely
it's just it's extreme it's too extreme
it's so extreme
so it was really good we have a lot of
tv to catch up on this week last week i
did not watch anything so i'll be
watching like everything in
threes pretty much except for the
bachelor which is on
tonight yes so we were we are back on
with the tv recaps this week i apologize
um for not watching i just like couldn't
do it i understand
i i couldn't either i was just in
another place um
reading watching period pieces and it
was lovely i'm so happy for you yeah but
now i'm back on the grind sometimes
self-care looks like hard work guys
yes so if you're listening as a podcast
stay tuned for an amazing interview with
jasmine sullivan from sports illustrated
sanders oh god sorry jasmine sanders
from the sports illustrated swimsuit
edition
and that's it that's all she wrote and
she actually wrote a lot today so we
will see you
tomorrow bye
you